i get asked very often you know what are
the most important characteristics of
leadership
vision charisma you know i know plenty
of incredible leaders that aren't
big steve jobs visionaries you know
they're just not and i know some
fantastic leaders who do not have
charisma
they're quiet and super introverted you
know and they're just not that exciting
to talk to
spend time with
uh when i say charisma i mean the
traditional definition of it which is
more about energy um i believe
charisma's undying belief in something
and that they have in spades but i think
courage
i think courage is the one thing that
all great leaders have to have
because we are surrounded by
overwhelming forces every day of our
lives
pushing us to play the finite game you
know if you're a public company
the the markets all they want for their
own selfish gain
is for you to make short term decisions
the pressures are overwhelming
um if you're a numbers driven person the
pressures are overwhelming
if you're in survival mode the pressures
are overwhelming if you have a spouse
who spends more money than you can make
the pressures are overwhelming
uh all the pressures around us even the
way we treat competition versus rivalry
like we feel like we have to win win win
all the the pressures every day on us
are absolutely overwhelming for us to be
finite
and to prioritize the short term over
the long term to prioritize the urgent
over the important
and it takes unbelievable courage to put
the important before the urgent
it takes unbelievable courage to resist
all the pressures coming from selfish
outside parties
it comes it takes unbelievable pressure
to do the right
thing so yeah encourages it
which begs the question how do you get
courage
yeah and the answer is you gotta have
people in your life who love you and
believe in you
wow uh you gotta have friends you gotta
have colleagues
you gotta have employees that when you
just don't have it in you
you just don't think you can you just
don't you just don't have it
somebody says uh
i got your back i believe in you
you